la planificación de los juegos olímpicos
de tokio no se detiene así lo expresó el
gobierno nipón tras la información
publicada por el diario británico the
times la cual aseguraba que las
autoridades japonesas veían inviables
sus celebraciones de verano
con respecto a los juegos serán un
símbolo de que la humanidad está
superando al cob y 19 y una oportunidad
para mostrar al mundo la reconstrucción
de japón después del terremoto y el
devastador tsunami sufridos en el
noreste estamos decididos a trabajar con
todas las autoridades competentes para
realizar unos juegos olímpicos seguro
en marzo del año pasado la pandemia
obligó a los organizadores a posponer el
evento deportivo más esperado del mundo
para finales de julio de 2021 el comité
olímpico internacional ha mostrado su
apoyo a través de un comunicado en sus
redes sociales y el director general de
la organización también ha querido
expresar su total compromiso para que
los juegos se inicien el próximo 23 de
julio
todos están realmente decididos a hacer
de estos juegos olímpicos' dentro de
seis meses la luz al final del túnel en
el que en este momento todavía estamos
momentos
la principal prioridad sería organizar
unos juegos seguros para todos los
participantes
aunque diversos comités olímpicos
nacionales hayan
respaldado la decisión un sondeo de la
cadena pública japonesa nh k reveló hace
una semana que sólo el 25 por ciento de
los japoneses están de acuerdo en que
los juegos se celebren este verano y la
oms pide que la decisión final se tome
de acuerdo a la situación sanitaria